- My first thought is
we love you!
And that's weird, but we do.
- It's weird yes I agree.
- I know we get it we're weird.
But um how did you like go
from being a dermatologist
to like this kind of phenomenon
thing happening to you?
Because obviously you didn't set out to be
Dr. Pimple Popper
- No, I did not
- [Kelly] I can't say it
Peter piped a pickled peppers, I can't,
Dr. Pimple Popper.
Yep, there you go.
- I mean, I've been in
practice since 2004.
But really about 4 years ago, I decided,
you know what, let me
start an Instagram page
and post some things about dermatology
and early on I posted a
blackhead extraction video
and I think people like
you guys paid attention.
You guys were like, "wait
a minute, what is this?"
And I just posted another one,
- You gotta get in there and get it out!
- And then look. 4 years
later it's a tv show,
I've got 3.5 million
followers on Instagram
and 3.5 billion viewers on YouTube.
(cheering)
- It's like
I'm like the Pied Piper of pimples.
- I know
- [Kelly] Don't give me more P's to say.
- Pied Piper of pimple popping
- I sing my little flute,
and you guys will follow me
- So wait, why are you so into it?
Do you just love the extractions?
- I've really been big into the extraction
for most of my life.
Um, both doing my own extraction
and um, seeing how things are extracted.
To know the right way to extract.
(laughing)
- How many times can she
say the word "extract"?
- No here's the thing.
You're not grossed out, right?
- Not at all. Nothing grosses me out
- Nothing grosses me out
- Really?
- Nothing.
- You're my people. That's right, yes.
- We are your views.
- Yeah because Kelly and
I were just talking about
the fact that I lay in bed at night
with the phone like right here
and I watch like so into it
and you're like right in my face.
- You should see my phone,
I'll show you some stuff
let me tell you.
- We get - My husband - We're weird
we get excited when you can't reach it
and I'm like "Oh I got it, I'll get it."
(laughing)
- Yes, yes. You know it's
all because of satisfaction
it makes you feel good, doesn't it?
- Very good, yes.
- Its so interesting that
is really kind of shocking
I think it's closure, you feel like
you - something - you've
put something back,
which you know put things back in place.
And you feel happy for those people.
Especially on the show, where you see
really, really extravagant kind of pops.
You know, and now you get to see them
kind of put back to normal
and it makes you feel good.
Isn't that interesting,
that something so gross
can make you feel good.
- [Kelly] Yes! - It's really nice.